bonsoir messieurs merci d'être en direct
avec nous alors pour bien comprendre ce
qu'est ce qui pose problème précisément
avec ce vaccin britannique au delà du
fait qu'il ne soit pour l'heure efficace
qu'à 70% karim khelfaoui ce qui pose
problème avec ce vaccin a été six hommes
pour les locales et tous les médecins
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on va avoir une
crise de confiance dans la manière de
son produit de ces vaccins parce qu'elle
est extrêmement rapide donc il va
falloir s'attendre à ce qu'il y ait une
défiance aussi de la population et à mon
avis pour aller contre ça il va falloir
qu'il y ait une transparence qui soit la
plus totale dans la manière dont ils ont
été produits de la sécurité qui doit
autour de ces vaccins et l'efficacité
qu'ils ont et il va falloir aussi
répondre à la question sur la possible
mutation du virus ce qui est pour
répondre à ces vaccins à être efficace
sur une période si un nombre peut-être
assez courte
sais tu as tout ça c'est à voir alors
stéphane gagné la mise en la mise au
point d'un vaccin de qualité est un
processus complexe qui nécessite parfois
plusieurs années de test ça veut dire
quoi en fait ces résultats est-ce qu'il
faut pas se méfier de tous ces vaccins
contrôle kobe de 19 qui apparaissent
moins d'un an après le début de la crise
sanitaire
on comprend que lier une méfiance parce
que comme vous l'avez un sous-entendu en
temps normal c'est à dire face à une
maladie chronique
le développement d'un vaccin mais des
années et des années et là on a voulu
accélérer énormément il faut dire aussi
qu'il existe une compétition féroce
entre les laboratoires multinationaux et
cette compétition féroce à vous tire un
empressement
il faut aller très vite il faut alors
les laboratoires sont amenés à
sous-traiter il y a une difficulté pour
obtenir suffisamment de volontaires et
ce qui s'est passé avec astrazeneca qui
est par ailleurs à laboratoire qui
produit des médicaments de l'excellente
réputation est connu dans tout le monde
ce qui s'est passé c'est que le
certainement ils ont voulu aller trop
vite ils ont
probablement enfin je le présume sous
traiter avec des enquêteurs qui
n'avaient peut-être pas l'habitude des
puits venus une erreur est survenue
c'est à dire que une petite corne à a eu
la moitié de la dose lors de la première
injection
bon alors ensuite ils ont fait une
moyenne des résultats mais la surprise
est qui qui nous concerne c'est que les
l'accorte qui a eu la moitié de la dose
lors de la première injection puis la
dose complète leur deuxième injection
paradoxalement et semble s'être
nettement mieux immunisés que l'autre
corps donc ces résultats déjà montre on
pouvait le craindre qu' il peut y avoir
des erreurs dans le déroulement et des
essais malgré toutes les précautions
malgré toutes les vérifications que l'on
fait et surtout là on ne comprend pas
bien ce qui s'est passé sur le plan
immunitaire et je crois que c'est ça
surtout qui est important c'est que
depuis le début de la pandémie
ce virus sascoc 2 ne fait que nous
étonner
il nous surprend tous les jours il nous
surprend par son pouvoir pathogène
on a affaire à un virus que l'on pensait
respiratoires et qui est à moitié
digestif est en grande partie également
vasculaire il se retrouve dans tous les
vaisseaux du corps il à tropisme
neurologiques donc un pouvoir pathogène
est inhabituel et puis il suscite une
réaction immunitaire également kiki qui
n'est pas habituel parce que dans un
premier temps bron tout semble se passer
comme avec une autre infection virale
et puis dans sa nausée dans un second
temps il y à cet emballement immunitaire
alors qu'est ce que l'on peut évoquer
comme explication possible
on sait que de temps en temps il y a eu
des en quelque sorte des erreurs de la
part du système immunitaire qui fabrique
des anticorps non pas neutralisant ou
bloquant mais des anti corps facilitant
et ça arrive de temps en temps et ces
anticorps facilitant loin de protéger
au contraire ils rendent plus
vulnérables à l'infection arsène wenger
sont issus de ce tps m
à dire pour autant ces erreurs que ce
vaccin soit bon être jeté à la poubelle
surtout pas surtout pas et surtout que
c'est une technologie très intéressante
c'est la même technologie que le vaccin
russe c'est à dire c'est un c'est un
vaccin un vecteur à adénovirus mais
inactive et alors on arrive à karim
khelfaoui les récentes annonces des
autorités européennes d'une campagne de
vaccination qui pourrait démarrer tout
prochainement en janvier 2021 sont-elles
prématuré selon vous je pense que en
fait dans le contexte comme l'a très
bien dit mon confrère où il ya une
compétition extrêmement féroce pour être
les premiers à avoir un vaccin et où
finalement on a extrêmement peu de recul
avec certains vaccins qui font appel à
des nouvelles technologies je pense aux
vaccins à air air on a absolument aucun
recul sur ce qui se passe sur ce qui a
été fait la transparence n'est pas au
rendez vous et je crois que la confiance
n'est pas forcément au rendez vous non
plus donc à mon avis que devrait
demander les autorités sanitaires et en
particulier européennes
c'est justement qu'on sorte de cette
logique de compétition qu'on mette en
commun les données et les informations
qui ont été liés aux recherches des
différents des différents laboratoires
en réalité tous les laboratoires ont
développé des vaccins à partir d'argent
public sanofi en france a touché plus de
200 millions d'euros d'argent public
pour développer un vaccin
donc il serait normal que la société
n'ait pas à payer deux fois ces vaccins
et et donc qu'on se retrouve pas parce
que là on a un gouvernement qui nous
explique que ça va être gratuit mais
c'est pas gratuit c'est que c'est
l'assurance maladie qui va payer et on
réalité du coup c'est de nouveau le
contribuable qu'on paie deux fois à ces
vaccins
donc moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui les
autorités sanitaires françaises
européennes devraient justement demandé
l'abandon
des brevets c'est possible légalement
elles peuvent le faire pour avoir
justement la possibilité de reproduire
ces vaccins à haute dose ont pris l'idée
est de pouvoir s'assurer de toute la
sécurité sanitaire aujourd'hui si on
arrive et qu'on a uniquement des
rapports d'autorités sanitaires qui nous
disent allez-y vous pouvez y aller où on
n'y allait pas et qu'on n'a pas accès à
l'ensemble des données qui a pas une
transparence la plus totale je crains
que les campagnes de vaccination soit
extrêmement difficile parce que la
population ne voudra pas y avait comment
ils allaient dans ce contexte alors
qu'on voit déjà
l'enjeu de 2,4 capitalistique des
profits qui sont fait à part ses fientes
hourmat ce tic dans le contexte actuel
qu'on connaît de défiance
quand on voit les annonces de deux files
heures qui a tout de suite a fait
flamber sa cote en bourse et que
automatiquement les quais les gens ont
vendu leurs actions et se sont retrouvés
à faire une plus value de plusieurs
millions d'euros
on a forcément ça crée de la défiance
donc aujourd'hui l'enjeu c'est justement
de retourner dans le domaine public
toutes ces recherches qui auraient déjà
été financés par de l'argent public et à
mon avis il ya une là il ya une action
qui commence eelv a commencé le 30
novembre une initiative citoyenne
européenne à l'appel de citoyens mais
aussi de syndicats de angie telle
association etc
je suis un des initiateurs de cette
action citoyenne
si on atteint les 1 million de
signatures on la commission européenne
sera obligé de statuer sur la
possibilité de faire sauter les brevets
et de récupérer dans le champ public
l'ensemble ces recherches pour pouvoir
les vérifier et les étendre alors
stéphane gagné on l'a dit la confiance
n'est pas forcément au rendez vous
puisque ces vaccins sont on peut le dire
un créé dans la précipitation quand même
puisque dix mois c'est très rapide pour
la création d'un vaccin et qu'elles
aient l'assurance qu'on peut avoir sur
justement l'absence de risque d'un
vaccin est ce qu'on peut savoir ça on a
un bon jour un risque il ya toujours un
risque
les vaccins font habituellement partie
et des médicaments sûrs
rapport à d'autres médicaments par voie
orale qui pour certains ont des effets
secondaires fréquents mais c'est le prix
à payer pour avoir les effets
thérapeutiques
habituellement les vaccins sont des
médicaments préventifs
ah c'est sûr mais on n'aura jamais de
garantie totale
là on est pressé par le temps on sent
très bien qu'il y à un affolement
un empressement à voir vouloir aller
vite et on peut on peut parler parce que
ça a été dit des effets secondaires qui
ont dû être supporté par les volontaires
sains et d'ores et déjà notamment avec
les deux premiers vaccins dont on a
parlé le vaccin files air et moderna et
bien les ailes et volontaires sains ont
eu des effets secondaires importants de
calme dans quel type
en effet ce grenelle nom de la fièvre
une sensation de malaise général des
douleurs musculaires ou articulaires et
puis une très grande fatigue
bon ça ne dure pas longtemps ça dure 48
heures au maximum trois jours mais c'est
quand même important et on a été surpris
par l'importance de ses effets
secondaires
tout se termine bien mais ça ça montre
bien que ces vaccins déclenché des
réactions qui peuvent être très violente
je dirais que actuellement on confère à
10 on est dans un climat qui est malsain
très malsain avec cette compétition pour
pour les vaccins et vous confère à
parler des brevets il a tout à fait
raison
les sommes en jeu sont tellement
faramineuses que c'est malsain
on ne peut pas être dans une sérénité et
cc c'est à couteaux tirés entre allait
les différents laboratoires et
évidemment tout ça ça suscite des ça
suscite des craintes et d'autant plus
qu' on a affaire à des nouvelles
technologies c'est à dire les
technologies pour fighter et modern
actions des technologies arn messagers
sont des technologies nouvelles que nous
n'avons pas encore utilisé ce n'est pour
les vaccins humains
stéphanie galiègue qui interrompt
puisque l'interview touche à sa fin
merci
pour cet éclairage stéphane caillet je
rappelle qu'au vieux infectiologues au
chu de strasbourg
merci à vous également karim khelfaoui
médecin généraliste à marseille merci
beaucoup à tous les deux